twitter in turn has started its own
campaign flagging the accounts of
state-affiliated media with
special labels such pages and their
posts will no longer be amplified
through the network's recommendation
systems
the pages of senior government officials
will also be labeled though at first
this would only apply to politicians who
represent the five
permanent members of the u.n security
council the company describes its new
policy as important for users
we believe this is an important step so
that when people see an account
discussing geopolitical issues
from another country they have context
on its national affiliation
and are better informed about who they
represent
okay let's look at which media have been
included on twitter's government
affiliated list
the label is now being shown in the
accounts of russia's rt and sputnik as
well as
of some chinese media outlets including
the country's official press agency and
two major newspapers
other outlets that one might have
thought would be on the list
they have been led off though among them
the uk's bbc and america's mpr twitter
says it won't label these as state
financed atlas because of their
editorial independence according to the
company's blog
independent media don't use their news
coverage to advance political agendas
twitter's labeling policies also
affected some editorial staff of
state-affiliated outlets including rt's
editor-in-chief marguerita siminyan
and the editor of china's global times
newspaper
auntie has sent a request to the company
to explain in detail the labeling
criteria
still waiting for their response
independent journalist martin summers
told us twitter's labeling policy is
intertwined with the global political
situation
i think there's an awful lot of politics
involved in this
as we know um twitter and the other
social media giants are coming under
pressure from all sorts of political
quarters
about what kind of policies they pursue
who they allow on their
on their sites uh what sort of uh
labeling they give to people who appear
on their sites
what is probably significant here is
this increase
in discrimination and
effectively censorship is because the
political
situation internationally is becoming
more and more stressed
uh and we're moving closer and closer to
confrontations
and it's a it's you know it's a rather
worrying sign of
uh that's this kind of development